until you callus over the victims
mentality that the world is out to get
you because of you are the only you got
a change - man not giving a civilized is
about having a savage mentality I ran a
hundred one miles like 19 hours and I
was like peeing dirt out of me wanna
sore get a mentor
[Music]
hey it's Evan Carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back a lack of belief in yourself
you watch these videos because you know
there's something more inside you you've
got Michael Jordan level talent at
something so today let's learn from one
of the best David Goggins and how to
develop a warrior mindset mentor me
Goggins
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one change your internal dialogue the
most important conversation is the one
you have with yourself you wake up with
it you walk around with it you go to bed
with it eventually you act on it
sometimes you act on it good sometimes
bad you've got to change the internal
dialogue that person in your head that's
talking that to you until you change the
internal dialogue in your head until you
callus over the victims mentality that
the world is out to get you because of
you are the only you got change - man
yeah but you don't understand my life
David yeah I do that's the thing about
it and that's why I can talk about but
yeah I give your saying a lot of folks
don't under
that mentality I once had that mentality
that no one understands what the going
through and if you keep that mentality
you're gonna stay in the same exact spot
that you're in that no one understands
me there's a whole there's millions of
people why do you think a book that I
self-published you know is doing so well
with the story that's so good like I'll
never give up I went to a publishing
house like who's gonna resonate with
this story no one's gonna buy this book
I'm like are you not in the world are
you not in society you're never alone
everybody's going through so when people
get this mentality of like you
understand me you can throw a lock to
someone that can understand you if
they're willing to break themselves down
and stop hiding a lot of people
understand you mmm but you got to stop
hiding and that's why I tell people a
lot of people are going through they
just hide better than you did that's all
I did it was hiding better rule number
two have
savage mentality not given civilized is
about having a savage mentality
civilized is something where people it's
a comfortable world a lot of us say you
know like for instance I see these
athletes right now who retire you know
I'm 38
you know I'm 39 I did 20 years at the
top of my game and I'm chilling out now
you seem a year later and how they look
what the hell just happened to you do
what the hell you're when the greatest
athletes of all time kids looked up to
you women men of all ages looked up to
you and they hit the pinnacle where it's
time to retire and their mind says I'm
civilized the worst thing that could
ever happen to any human being is they
become civilized
it's that total accountability like even
when you retired as I'm looking at me
and judging me right now man um I was
the baddest person to ever live it
doesn't go away man you got to wake up
even though you retired you never
retired you're setting the example every
single day of your life and being
civilized feels so good I'm sorry man
once you get to the top you may retire
but you ain't never coming back home and
now you're judged people see you falling
off you want to be that guy who knows I
may be retired from the sport or forever
I did but I'll be damned if you ever see
me looking like feeling like not
arriving people I've arrived I've
arrived mentality you're always setting
the example civilization feels so good
these comfortable feelings on what
people want they want retirement they
want that they need that they it's a
yearning feeling I want it to people
love put a label on me about my god man
you're just wired different why are
different dude I'm thinking right now
after I got past my stuttering thing now
I'm on a roll I'm good now you don't
think about right now I got wake up
tomorrow and do the same again I got
leave this
interview and go stretch out for two and
a half hours I hate that but guess what
it does though I'm constantly callous
and over my victims mentality that I
once had growing up every day you have
to do this because why when you stop
doing it you don't just maintain it if
you stop shooting a gun not gonna be a
great shot you pick a gun up a year from
now the only way to keep from getting
rusty is to constantly all that machine
the machine is this you got to keep
challenging it every day also if you
want to have more confidence check out
my 254 series they're free the links to
join are in the description below
everything I didn't want to do is what
got me to where I'm at today you will
never learn from people if we always
tap-dance around the truth it's about
what you're saying to yourself but it
also comes at work so whenever I was
getting beat down physically mentally
spiritually whatever I was going through
just saying you know I would put you
know you can't hurt me rule number three
push yourself to the extreme when I got
through with that first hundred mile
race that I did around that one-mile
track that didn't prepare for and I was
considerably it was horrible and I'll
never forget I found such peace and
beauty and I got there I was in the
worst pain of my life and I got done and
my wife pulled the car up on the my
ex-wife pulled the car up on this little
lawn and I got in the back of it and I
got the stairs I'm not gonna go through
the whole story but I remember laying in
the tub and she put the shower on me and
I ran a hundred one miles like 19 hours
and I was like peeing dirt out of me and
I'm sitting there and I'm jackhammering
and my body is just the most broken has
ever been even to this day and this
feeling came over me I call it crazy if
you want but very few people I guarantee
of ever felt this before to push
themselves so far outside of what they
thought was even possible even for me I
laid in that tub
and I didn't want it to go away I had
drained myself of every bit
of strength energy I had and it was the
best feeling ahead of my life all that
pain it was it was confirmation
it was confirmation that I had gone
through a crucible and I figured out
another level of David Goggins a level
that I thought was humanly impossible
for anybody to do when I was at Mile 70
and pissed all over myself and had 30
more miles to go and I was damn near
dead and I was able to go 31 more miles
in that process of the next 31 more
miles I found out more about myself in
that 31 miles than ever had in my entire
life the conversations the mental blocks
the roadblocks to everything horrible it
was just feeding at me like Lightspeed
get the out of here man like I was able
to figure out different tactics and when
I finally got done with that elating
that tub and it was over the feeling of
my god man you just really discovered a
whole new world a whole new part of the
brain that guarantee very few people
have rule number four take
accountability one big thing is the
accountability man mmm you have to start
with yourself so what happened in in my
life was we start to get I call it like
the rucksack a rucksack is a pack that
you carry in the military and you put
all your stuff in it your radios your
food your water all that stuff you have
to carry the military that's your
rucksack it's a backpack pretty much as
you're growing up we all have a backpack
most of ours hopefully is empty you know
and what we put in it is all the crap we
go through in life that's what is in the
backpack for the civilians and we carry
it around with us so what you have to
start doing is realizing that no matter
where you're at in life I got called
[ __ ] a lot my dad abused me you know
learning disability stutters immaturity
insecurities self doubt so much crap on
top of me so much stuff I lied a lot to
create friends so people so much stuff
was in my backpack no one's coming
back to help me so it starts with that
person in that mirror you have to
realize you are on your own now and
whatever else you believe in I don't
care what you believe in but on earth
it's a very lonely journey it starts
with the accountability mirror of
looking at saying hey my daddy beat the
hell he's not coming back all these
things are coming back I have to face
myself and you have to own all those
things that people may have done to you
now it's yours you got to own it it's
yours now to fix the problems that
people did to you it makes no sense it's
not fair I get it
but if you live in that what was me
mentality of guess what my dad did this
to me my mom just did to me
people who bullied did this to me you're
gonna always live right there you have
to figure out ways to move forward
because you're not coming back it starts
with the mirror I call it the
accountability mirror in the book and
rule number five the last time we for a
very special bonus clip is adapt to the
suck a lot of us dream big you should
dream big big big is important you know
some of us won't be doctors lawyers
dentists towards morning they'll want
one of these special operations so you
have this big dream you can see so
clearly it's right in front you can go
out and touch it
but the thing about it is somewhere if
you dream big enough somewhere down that
journey that dream becomes a nightmare
and what happens in that nightmare so
they have all these questions like if
you want to be a special ops you may not
be a great swimmer you may just realize
that I'm not great some out on that
great runner you may start to fail tests
and all these questions talk to fledge
your mind why am I here I'm not good
enough trust me I know all about the
questions they will flood your mind if
you do not have the answers for them you
will quit the answers lie in the
repetitions you must not forget the
repetitions you put into trying to
dominate the crap that you're in the day
always always embrace the suck adapt
this up now I've got a special bonus
clip from David on how to stop making
excuses that I really think you're gonna
enjoy but before that it's time for the
three-point landing questions let's go
from just watching the video
to take in action here we go question
number one
what's the suck that you need to adapt
to number two what's the most important
internal dialogue that you need to
change and number three where do you
need to take more accountability and if
you're gonna take immediate action after
watching this video give me a hash tag
believe down then the comments as well
so which of its juice it's a to coal
where you live is it too hot where you
live doesn't rain too much nice timer
some roof talk maybe you're the only
black person applying for a job maybe
the only female maybe the only gay
person job whatever it may be
maybe that sits in your head maybe
that's your excuse for not being better
life's a real big picture when I was
young all those things got my head black
not smart enough single mom all their
books oh space in my head if you're
allowing people and things and
situations choice patient then you're
losing last thing last one big head game
you play with yourself if you lose it's
because you allow life to get in your
head stay hard
if you want one hour of David Goggins
motivation check out their video right
there next to me I think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there
the mind is like honestly it has a
tactical advantage over us it knows our
deepest darkest fears or insecurities it
knows